one very small site in Greece that has
had a tremendous impact on our modern
world is the sanctuary of the god Zeus
and the goddess Hera at a little place
called Olympia Olympia was named for
Mount Olympus in northern Greece where
these two gods were located as having
their home address in classical times
but its origins go much further back in
time to the Bronze Age and the heroic
world and it established a pattern of
games as a form of worship that evolved
into a quadrennial a four yearly
festival of sports of athletics of
competitions that were revived in 1896
to become our modern Olympic Games
present to us in this idea of the games
in honor of a god are two very
contrasting and conflicting elements of
the Greek personality one is a love and
an admiration for a gone or contest
agon is of course the Greek word from
which we get agony striving struggle
pain they believed in that as a test of
human beings and they believe that
agonies contests were the true measure
of a person whether a man or at Olympia
where there were also games for young
women a girl at Olympia we also see a
Greek interest in Pan Hellenism all
embracing Greek nosov Greeks from all
city-states Islands places of habitation
from the Black Sea all the way out to
the western Mediterranean to come back
to this central spot tucked away in a
remote corner of the western Peloponnese
to take part during a summer once every
four years in five days of celebrations
and rituals and above all unless you're
an athlete watching the very best
athletes in your world participate in
these holy rituals these gains now it
would happen months before the contest
started that the Herald's would go out
through Greece calling the athletes to
come to Olympia for a mandatory period
of training before the games everyone
else followed all the thousands of
spectators in some cases tens of
thousands of spectators a few months
later in midsummer so let's join that
crowd now and make our way to Olympia to
have our experience of the original
Olympic Games in many ways so very
different from the modern games that
they have inspired as we approached
Olympia today we will come by road car
or in a bus and I really recommend
arriving in the afternoon at a time when
you can check into your hotel in the
modern little town of Olympia which has
grown up outside the sacred sanctuary
and the archaeological site this modern
town Olympia being dedicated totally
toward the service of tourists and
archaeologists from your hotel you can
then walk through the town to the
entrance the sacred site will be
afternoon the day is starting to get
cool light is starting to get golden the
shadows of the trees and there are many
at Olympia are beginning to lengthen as
you walk across the bridge over the
river
Claudio's one of two rivers at whose
convergence the sanctuary of Zeus and
Hera was planted by the Greeks on the
other side you have a choice to go left
towards the Archaeological Museum which
I recommend leaving until the next day
the morning of your second day of
staying at Olympia instead go forward a
bit till you come to the gates which
mark not only the modern but the ancient
entrance to the holy sanctuary of Zeus
and Hera at Olympia show your tickets
walk in
take a little drink of water because
this may be a hot walk even in the
afternoon and begin to retrace the steps
of all those Greek athletes of long ago
let's talk a little bit about what their
experience would have been they would
have fought their way to the top as
runners as track and field stars as
charioteers even as things like heralds
and trumpeters in order to have this
supreme honor of entering that gate as a
competitor we are just coming in in
their wake as spectators people who will
derive tremendous joy unforgettable
memories from being here and seeing the
best of the best
compete once every four years the
tradition began according to the Greeks
way back in the year 776 BC back in the
8th century which was also the century
of the the rise of homers epics and the
rise of the Greek city-state the Olympic
Games were born there too and the Games
held every four years became such
landmarks in the Greek experience they
counted time with them they will say
that such and such a thing occurred in
the third year of the 58th Olympiad or
something like that ultimately there
were to be almost 300 Olympiads ending
for the end of the Roman period when the
games were closed by the Christian
Emperor's but we are back in the heyday
of the games we are coming into a sacred
place where we find immediately on our
left a pretty a on a building for the
presiding officers of the Olympic Games
nobody lived at Olympia then there were
two neighboring towns or little
city-states Ellis and Pisa that fought
over the right to control the games and
one or the other would be in control at
any given time their officials would be
in that little house with the
everlasting hearth fire ready to welcome
winners and distinguished guests
celebrities from all over the Greek
but on our right as we enter a rather
nondescript set of ruins today is
something that every athlete or at least
most of the athletes would have been
drawn to as to a magnet and that is the
gymnasium where some of the track and
field stars would practice during the
days running up to the games within that
enormous gymnasium so big that it's hard
for us to recognize as a building there
was a running track which matched the
length of the original stadium the real
stadium for the running events off on
the other side of the site so that
athletes could practice on a track that
exactly matched the course they would
run once they were out in the open
before the gaze of up to 40,000
spectators at the event itself who would
have practiced here in this gymnasium to
your right while all the runners the
track within the big stadium was about
six hundred and thirty feet long so the
runners who are either going to run one
length of the track or two they'll turn
around a post and come back so they'd be
running something like a 440 yards
they're going to be practicing there and
also some of the field athletes the
javelin throwers because that's a the
same place they'll be performing for
their hurling of the javelin and the
discus throwers also will be practicing
on this long track in the gymnasium we
keep on walking forward headed south and
we now come to our left a late comer
among the great buildings of Olympia a
circular building a tholos from the
circular base of which rise beautiful
ionic marble columns in a circle and
inside were the portraits of three very
important people fill up the second king
of Macedon in the middle and late part
of the 4th century BC is wife Olympius
queen of Macedon and their son Alexander
eventually to become known as Alexander
the Great why are they here they are
here because of that idea that olympia
was a Panhellenic shrine the macedonian
rulers were Greek they spoke
creak they were descended from Greeks
who had gone north to Macedon and set
themselves up as a ruling dynasty over
Macedonian tribes but there was some
argument about whether they had lost
their Greek necessar of philip ii in the
previous century had won the right to
compete in the olympic games as a greek
after a scrutiny by the city-state that
was in charge of the games at that time
philip ii wanted to reassert that claim
we the kings of Macedon are Greeks
because he was setting himself up to be
recognized as the leader supreme the
king the commander-in-chief of all
Greeks he wanted to use the Panhellenic
tradition at olympia to create the idea
of a Panhellenic political unit with
himself and later his son Alexander
as the head so you are looking at a
beautiful ionic piece of propaganda here
plunked down right in your path where no
visitor can miss it at the very
beginning of the special buildings that
lead one into the magic world of Olympia
at the same time as we look to the right
we see another building very close to
that Philip pay on that monument to
Philip it is the palaestra tal a EST RA
the palaestra not a word that came over
to our modern athletic jargon as
gymnastics the place for an important
set of athletes to work out it's a small
square open to the Sun with colonnades
and little changing rooms all around it
the colonnades are a spectacular
landmark here is where the wrestlers
would train here's where the boxers
would train here is where the all-in
wrestlers would train the kick boxers
the pancreas who could use all methods
to try to defeat their opponents than
sometimes the pen Crotty on which means
the all-in fighters are the total force
fighters they actually fought to the
death it was a wildly popular event but
a very troubling one to some spectators
their training here and someone who's
going to participate in the pin
flan the long jumpers will also be in
this palaestra away from the runners and
the javelin throwers and discus throwers
who were in the longer open space of the
cogniser
beyond that palaestra still on our right
is a building whose function was not
immediately understood when German
archaeologists first started digging at
the site back in the 19th century this
building matched in its size the sella
the inner sanctuary of the temple of
zeus and it was finally realized this
was the workshop in which the great
Athenian sculptor Phidias had created
what became literally a wonder of the
world
the gigantic statue of zeus made on a
wooden core covered with gold and ivory
and therefore called chris elephantine
chris say for the gold
the elephantine from the elephants in
the ivory that was ultimately put on the
official list in the Hellenistic period
of the seven wonders of the world the
excavation of this workshop was a
tremendous excitement for the
archaeologists involved they found
Phidias tools they found the molds in
which he had formed the drapery for the
statue they found some of the little
spatulas that were used to work with
gold leaf they found remains of his his
materials like the the gold and and
ivory chips and bits and pieces of
obsidian and other precious substances
and they apparently found even the great
man's drinking cup because from among
the debris of this studio this workshop
which had been like the rest of Olympia
covered by successive floodings of the
Alphaeus and Claudius rivers which
deposited layer after layer of silt to
cover over the buildings the ruins no
Town was ever built there so they
weren't desecrated and the stones
carried away as in so many places just
sealed in this little cup and the cup
had scratched on the bottom the two
words
phidias Amy I belong to phidias in the
same way that you might take a cup of
styrofoam or plastic at a party and
write your name on the bottom
so no one else would drink out of it
phidias worked for years on this statue
of zeus in the middle of the 5th century
BC the very height of the Greek
classical and Golden Age period with a
large team of assistants he knew he was
creating something special
Olympia wasn't a sight like Athens or
one of the other city-states it was a
Panhellenic place a spot where all
Greeks would come and see his work and
he wanted to create a masterpiece he
built the zeus in sections it was
carried over from his workshop across
the way to the temple take it in and
placed toward the western end of the
temple so you could view it straight
ahead of you as you came into the doors
at the far east end and be overwhelmed
by this God seated on his throne and
robed in solid gold apparently gleaming
with the white ivory for his skin
crowned with some sort of golden diadem
it was sometimes complained as an
artistic point that if he tried to stand
up this statue he would have hit his
head on the roof that's how gigantic he
was but everyone accepted him as the
ultimate standard of classical art and
it is a tremendous grief to us that in
this case we don't have souvenir
examples there were just a few coins
from the time of the Emperor Hadrian
where a design that looks like it must
be a representation of that seated Zeus
from Olympia appeared stamped on one
side of the coin as we exit Phidias
workshop area and don't be confused by
the Christian crosses here and there
part of it was taken over later to be a
church in the very early Christian
period as we exit let's look now more
closely at that temple off to our right
is the the building called the Leonie
Dion this was a hotel for high-class
guests we're not high-class enough to
stay there we're going to just make our
way to the temple and we will find
looming ahead of us on a high stone
podium the remains of the temple of zeus
immediately clear it was knocked down by
an earthquake you can see the Fallen
column drums in stacks like
so many cookies coming out column after
column row after row of drums from the
temple on either side in fact it looks
like it would be a pretty simple job to
put them back together the Greeks have
decided not to put them back together
but they have created at one corner of
the temple the northwest corner a new
column to give you a sense of the height
the majesty of the original colonnades
that surrounded the temple of zeus there
sometimes when you are allowed to walk
up the steps and cross the the podium of
the base of the temple itself last time
I was there you couldn't do that
this goes for almost everything that you
hear about or read about in a guidebook
to Greece you just never know what
access you will have when you make your
own trip so be prepared for some
disappointment I was certainly
disappointed last time with a group of
students not to be able to walk up the
steps and walk through the temple but
take it with good grace the
Archaeological Service is trying to do
their best to preserve and also to work
on some new restorations so we have to
roll with the punches if we go off to
the far end of the temple of zeus this
central thing for the olympic game since
they were in his honor i would like you
to look for at the far end the east end
a triangular column base this originally
held on its top a beautiful and very
famous statue called the winged victory
the winged victory or nike of the
Messenians a people who inhabited the
southwestern corner of the Peloponnese
who had been continually downtrodden by
the spartans but since in the 420 s bc
they've managed to finally combined with
the athenians and beat the spartans for
once they hired a sculptor to create
this winged victory holding a palm in
her hand foot coming down onto the top
of the triangular column as if she was
landing from an airplane there she stood
outside the door where all the spartan
competitors would have to walk by and
see her and be reminded yes those
machine Ian's did beat us once this is
perhaps the place to talk about what it
really meant for the Greeks to be at the
Olympic Games this idea of the agon the
competition and contests that goes on
beyond
these sacred precincts I remember going
to Olympia once with my professor Greek
history professor Donald Kagan of Yale
he sat down on a stone the rest of us
sat down under the olive trees around
him and he lectured to us about the
Greek Olympic ideal it was a bishop of
Pennsylvania who created the expression
of the modern Olympic ideal which you
may have heard so often that ideal that
says it is not the winning but the
taking part nothing could be more alien
to the ancient Greek idea of an agon or
contest than to say that all it mattered
was to take part the games at Olympia
the other games the crown games at Nemea
to Zeus at the east boast to Poseidon at
Delfy to Apollo they're all about
winning there are no second and third
prizes there's a winner and there are
losers winners got to have statues made
of their bodies portraits of their
bodies after they'd won three times at
Olympia songs were made about them they
were given free dinners for life in the
town hall of their home town they were
considered like gods and the little
winning ribbons were wrapped around
their heads like diadem's of gods or
heroes they were considered something
more than human but what's the other
side of the coin the losers are
considered nothing they have to crawl
home in shame they creep around their
hometowns in alleys hoping no one will
notice them they are mortified for the
rest of their lives that they lost at
Olympia there is an arrogance about the
winning go to Homer read his heroes
talking to each other and you will find
that you are looking at the origins of
our modern tradition of trash talking at
athletic events that's much closer to
the ancient Greek ideal then this idea
of just taking part is a wonderful
enhancement of life now let's go up to a
place now very much closer to the heart
of the athletes experience we are going
north
now after getting to the East End of the
temple and we are moving to an open
space where the plaques will tell you in
this spot once sacred to the mother of
the gods the flame is kindled for the
modern Olympic torch there is a little
bowl there of reflecting metal or mirror
like material the sun's rays are caught
in that bowl so without any striking of
a match once it gets hot enough it
bursts into flame and our for yearly
Olympic flame in modern times is born
there's no evidence they had this kind
of ritual for the ancient games look to
the left and you're looking at the
temple of Harrah it's older than the
temple of zeus the worship of hera the
great goddess preceded that of zeus here
and the games for the girls and the
young women about which we know next to
nothing were held at olympia on a
regular basis at times when the men were
not there celebrating their games in
honor of zeus this temple of hera is a
very interesting Doric structure every
column is different with big flat plate
like capitals apparently it was
originally wooden way back on about 600
BC when it was created and the columns
were simply replaced as each wooden
column rotted and was judged that it
needed replacing so they were made by
different sculptors at different times
gives that temple a wonderful unique and
very different kind of appearance from
the standard clockwork precision of most
classical Greek Doric structures but
it's time for us to enter the stadium we
turn our backs now on the temple of
Harrah we go east if we are spectators
there is some way for us to get up over
the great berm of earth that encloses
the huge stadium area if we're
competitors we will see ahead of us a
little arched opening that leads into a
masonry vault a vaulted corridor or
tunnel leading from the outer sanctuary
into the stadium or study on that place
of what they call 600 feet laid out by
Heracles he had big feet
about 16 inches for each foot but it's
as I said today it's about 630 feet long
where most of the big track and field
events were held the athletes went into
this tunnel and they were standing in
something that until this tunnel was
discovered by the archaeologists nobody
believed existed
a true vault including true arches built
by Greeks long before the Romans so we
need to rewrite all the history books
and architectural books that are still
out there claiming credit for Roman
architects as the inventors of the arch
and the vault after their names are
called they would emerge into the
brilliant sunshine and take their places
for their events there were five days of
competitions the trumpeters and heralds
went first so they could be picked to
call the contestants either by trumpet
fanfare or by name up to the start or
the contesting place for their events
boys dominated the first day and the
next days were given over to things like
the pentathlon the pen Crotty on the
chariot races which were held on a race
track further out a much wider expanse
and so on right through until the fourth
day when it was prize-giving day and all
of the winners assembled to receive
their crowns of wild olive Zeus's own
wild olive and as those crowns settled
on their heads they became immortals
they became people whose fame and glory
in the minds of the Greeks would never
die the five linked Olympic rings are
sometimes claimed to be a symbol taken
from the ancient Greek Olympics that's
not true that's a modern
misunderstanding but I believe that
Baron the Coubertin who in 1896 revived
the Olympic tradition with a set of
Olympic Games given at Athens and a
stadium built on the side of the old
Panathenaic Games
I believe that Cooper 10 was inspired by
all of those wreaths those Victor's
wreaths or crowns that you see on
plaques and on statues having to do with
Olympic athletes to make his five rings
that represented the five continents of
the world draw
together by the Olympic competitions as
I said the crowd was about 40,000 people
there must have been structures there
that are now hidden or gone because we
know that in the early fifth century AD
at the time of the changeover to
Christian Emperor's an entire Roman army
was sent into quote endquote
destroy the stadium at olympia but you
can still see as you walk in over on the
right side the little area set apart for
the high priests and the judges you can
also see the sil the stone sill on the
ground that was the starting line for
the running races and you can take your
place there fitting your own toes into
those grooves squatting down and then on
the word of a friend taking off for a
run a trot perhaps a quiet amble up and
back the stadium at olympia but i urge
you to do it even if the best you can do
is take your walking stick and shuffle
along from the beginning to the far end
and back you will have been retracing
the steps of people especially the boys
whom the ancient world thought were the
absolute top of human development the
perfection of the sporting instinct and
the cult of the body the people after
whom all others should try to pattern
themselves be part of that wonderful
procession the stadium rounds out our
tour of the ancient game site as we come
out again through the tunnel notice some
pedestals for statues that are lining
your exit your penalty for having
cheated at olympia was to pay to have a
statue of zeus made and erected there
you could be mocked and reviled for all
time to come
again not exactly our idea of the
Olympic spirit it's not enough to have
seen the site at Olympia there are two
wonderful museums that I hope you will
visit also one is on the far side of the
river it's the Museum of the history of
the ancient Olympic Games and it has
marvelous things in it like the plaques
from as late as the late fourth century
AD when there had been almost 300
Olympiads that list some of the winners
to show that they had achieved this
superhuman state as olympic victors
there in the very end of the Olympic
tradition which was going to go out like
a light in 393 when the Emperor
Theodosius closed Olympia and almost all
the other pagan sanctuaries it's the
other Museum though where I urge you to
spend your most time the main
Archaeological Museum you will see the
great pedimental sculptures that showed
a pair of myths an Athenian myth that
showed Theseus the Athenian hero beating
some centaurs some half-man half-horse
monsters who'd come down to break up a
wedding reception and the god Apollo is
urging him on as Theseus and his friend
paratha was restore order out of chaos
and on the other side a great chariot
race a myth about a contest the chariot
races were very big and very popular at
Olympia in which the young hero Pelops
after whom Peloponnese island of Pelops
is named managed to beat a local king in
a chariot race and claim this great land
for his own you'll also see squares of
stone these are called the Metta peas
from the temple they show the labors of
Heracles Heracles of course associated
with Tiryns the Mycenaean Citadel on the
other side of the Peloponnese but
Olympia had been the site of one of his
labors he had diverted the rivers so
they ran through the stables the filthy
manure filled stables of King augeas and
achieved the seemingly impossible task
of cleaning out those stables he's there
too you see all 12 of his Labor's
represented on the meta peace elsewhere
you see treasures that were left at
Olympia over the ages in addition to all
of the monuments that we passed around
the site as we walk through it you have
to realize that buried underground were
offerings that ordinary people brought
to Olympia and left there and thanks to
the gods or in prayer for blessings yet
to come warriors and Generals brought
arms
and armor to bury under the ground and
the one that always excites me most is
the helmet of the great general milk
deities of Athens the man who
masterminded the victory of the
Athenians over the Persians at marathon
in 490 BC and who took his own helmet
and that of a Persian warrior that he
had either killed or captured down to
Olympia and offered to Zeus on the cheek
piece of the helmet or inscribed the
words you can make out the letters
yourself milk IDs to the god
you will see many other treasures
ranging from gigantic bronze cauldrons
left there for Zeus and for Hera to
small images of girls and women that may
have been left by some of the female
participants in the games of Hera but at
the end of your trip you will be led by
the pathway through the museum to a
special small sanctuary it's known from
a travel book written by the ancient
writer Pallas Aeneas that a beautiful
statue by the great Athenian sculptor
prax Italy's of the fourth century BC
was at Olympia it was in the temple of
Harrah and it showed Hermes the
messenger God the god of travel and
commerce holding the baby Dionysus god
of wine and intoxication when he's still
a child before drinking age in his arm
and he's dangling a bunch of grapes sort
of showing Dionysus what lies ahead when
the archaeologists excavated Olympia
they were astonished to find that the
earthen walls of the temple of Harrah
had collapsed inward if the temple had
been stone like the Temple of Zeus the
collapse of those walls probably in an
earthquake would have shattered
everything inside the temple but this
original marble statue of prax Italy's
was there it was buried in the earth
excavated by the archaeologists in the
19th century and let me tell you you
will never see such a representation of
the human body with a Polish of marble
worthy of Michelangelo
pietà as that Hermes holding little
Dionysus in his arm
Olympia is a place to return to again
and again it is a magical spot it is a
place where you can touch the ancient
world yourself by walking or running
that course by imagining yourself
working out in that ancient gymnasium or
Palestra enjoying the sensation of being
yet another pilgrim in an ongoing flow
of pilgrims who have come to this site
for inspiration for a vision of the past
and perhaps given that our life is still
a contest and we are still seeking
perfection in all things a vision of a
future that might yet be
you